hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute machen wir jayhawks schicken
nudelsieb schicken youtube schicken
wenn ihr in den letzten tagen auf der
trend seite unterwegs gewesen seid dann
habt ihr vielleicht den jayhawks neuen
song schicken nudelsieb gesehen sorge
dass ich ganz weit gehen hier darüber
mache aber ich finde diesen tanz so
witzig und falls sie nicht wissen wovon
ich spreche dann verlinke ich euch unten
mal das video in der infobox die meisten
wissen es bestimmt aber ich sage es noch
mal für die die es nicht tun jay hope
ist ein teil der koreanischen popband
bt11 okay man muss sie nicht mögen aber
kennen sollte man sieht mittlerweile
habt ihr ja meine vorliebe für pcs
mitbekommen ich weiß dann hier zu sehen
ein oder anderen dns triggert dass ich
jetzt so oft koreanische boys stehe aber
ein kenner singh duell beider teams ist
sehr folge live in einem living so eine
hühnersuppe kennen wir alle was will man
essen wenn man krank ist
nein
hühnersuppe ich will auf einen kleinen
trost reinbringt seehofer aus korea
stammt wollte ich mal meinen horizont
erweitern und eine koreanische schicken
juli zum ausprobieren für dieses gericht
habe ich ein rezept im internet gefunden
von einer richtig koreanischen mama da
karl kuck so doug heißt huhn und kalk zu
heiß geschnitten weil wir die nudeln
selber machen werden und sie so
schneiden wer und was brauchen wir um
uns so richtig koreanisch einzustellen
natürlich bts live phase ich meine
natürlich tabu
so ist der beliebteste koreanische
alkohol und dort trinkt ihn quasi jeder
deswegen gibt's auch viele alkoholiker
die man mit social antrifft ich finde
aber auch mittlerweile wichtig zu sagen
dass alkoholkonsum zu einer alkoholsucht
führen kann wenn man es nicht verträgt
und leider gibt es niemals so ein moment
wo man sagen kann wenn ich jetzt weiter
trinke werde ich alkoholkrank das kommt
schleichend und man merkt es kaum und
tatsächlich sind viele deutsche und auf
der ganzen welt alkoholkrank weil es da
draußen jemand interessiert ich trinke
privat alkohol zu besonderen anlässen
das heißt wenn ich mit freunden
unterwegs bin zu feiern geburtstag
hochzeit sowas und niemals zu hause
einfach so und wo ich das jetzt geklärt
habe groß und so ist reiswein und dieser
ist mit weintrauben geschmack und hat
zwölf prozent alkohol es gibt auch nach
dem original ohne geschmack mit 17
prozent das habe ich das erste mal in
new york im kreieren barbecue restaurant
probiert und ich finde da muss ich sagen
und eine sache musste ich im supermarkt
auch noch unbedingt mitnehmen kimchi ich
glaube kimchi ist genauso bip 2q und
zwar ist das cool mit seiner scharfen
passte eingelegt und das ist man in
korea quasi zu jedem gericht als so zeit
dass hier leute selbst gemachtes kimchi
ja sie ganz gute chancen ergreifen let's
try something to gaza ist es gar nicht
mal so schlecht dass selbst gemachte war
ein bisschen schärfer starb
hier zum herbst machen wir aber unsere
hausgemachte koreanische kino
was braucht man für eine hühnersuppe
natürlich ein huhn und das ist ein
ziemliches upgrade auf unserem letzten
video wo ich das hackfleisch benutzt
habe und da habe ich mich aber natürlich
wieder ein bio hähnchen gehalten für
zehn euro bekommt man hier 800 gramm
es ist eine haltungsform vier premium
und ich danke dem lieben gott für diese
gabe und hoffe das wohn hatte ein gutes
leben aber hier steht dass die bewegung
hatten in regelmässiger auslauf im
freien
und ich werde dich sehr ehren und danke
dir dass du meine mahlzeit wirst dann
brauchen wir noch zwiebeln und die waren
auch sehr glücklich das sind bio
zwiebeln dann brauchen wir noch
knoblauch und ingwer der aussieht wie
ein tanzender mensch laufen und dann
noch so eine koreanische sojasauce für
suppen die ein bisschen heller ist und
dadurch bleiben dann die suppen auch
hell
das habe ich leider nicht gefunden aber
ich habe keine waffe gefunden die kommt
aus hongkong und ich denke mal dass sie
auch passt denn asien so alles ist
gleich über drüben 16 auch irgendwie
alle gleich aus war ist besonders bts
also das sieht jeder aus wieder andere
immer rechts ist und für die nudeln
lieber später noch selber machen
brauchen wir mehr sei rapsöl und ein
bisschen wasser denn nudeln machen es
mega einfach schmeckt viel geiler und es
sogar noch günstiger
das war werbung für nudeln als in
finanzanlagen natürlich niemals aufhören
euch in zuflüssen influenza
ich war wirklich schön dass ich das
gesagt habe und jetzt kommen wir zur
zubereitung und dafür habe ich oft
gefragt ob er nicht vielleicht die
kamera halten kann dann machen wir ein
bisschen tippen nudelsuppe ja max
yahoo.de showdown ist natürlich jay hob
dank
ich habe schon ein top vorbereitet und
ein schneidebrett denn wir müssen für
unsere suppe gemüse schneiden damit das
alles zu sammeln mit dem wintertraining
kochen kann
das war japanisch also wir haben hier
den wechsel auf den finnen könnten
gewaltopfer müssen eine tolle branchen
gründlich waschen
leider habe ich nicht kenne school ist
asiatisches messe aber so geht's auch
was kommt in den topf nicht wundern
diese ganzen zu tragen sind halt für den
geschmack der brühe und nicht alle zum
essen
als ich da jetzt jemand gewundert hat
natürlich der fall war so viel fleiß ist
auf knoblauch darf auch in die suppen
party und wir brauchen acht stück also
18 weiß gerade nicht wie man so stark
gedrückt aber diese schöne der wahl
gestellt was sie mit deiner hand
geschält der sondermaschine
der 5 6 7 und 8
jetzt müssen wir unsere zwiebel in die
hälfte schneiden und eine halbe zwiebel
zu unserer sub hinzufügen jetzt wirklich
drauf gucken was wirken rein legen wir
holen jetzt den patienten rein doch erst
schon für eine längere zeit bewusstlos
und ich weiß nicht ob ihnen
wiederbeleben können aber lasst uns
versuchen um es entfaltet sich es war
zusammengequetscht drin
das ist ein richtiges mädchen so kinder
sieht chicken wings aus bevor ihr sie
bei casey kauft und so sieht das von
innen aus wir waren ja auch etwas lerne
hier sieht man die wirbelsäule da drin
sieht man noch die rippen es müssen wir
einfach münchen waschen schon heftiger
mit kleiner geworden
ja ich glaub ich bleib doch gar nicht
erst denken jetzt zu früh die darauf
jetzt drei liter wasser
[Musik]
irgendwie creepy dass ich gerade das
hühnchen sagen gegrinst
es tut mir leid also das muss jetzt für
ungefähr eine stunde kochen also ich
trinke auf durchmisst er öfter so kochen
dass man auch richtig das tier sieht
weil dann weiß man wirklich was man da
kocht wenn man so diese fertigen kugeln
gewusst dass ich da nicht mehr nach
fleisch also sieht noch fleisch aus aber
es sieht nicht mehr nach ihr aus die
sogar muss jetzt nach 20 minuten köcheln
aber wir können schon mal mit dem
noodles beginn und nudeln selbermachen
ist wirklich das einfachste auf der welt
wir brauchen drei kaps will 3 1 cup
wasser fasst ein teelöffel salz und ein
esslöffel fühlt sich julian herrmann und
ein kleiner tipp so zum teig kneten weiß
sorgt gemacht habe mit dem handballen da
habt ihr die meiste kraft dieses rezept
das wieder so richtig back to the roots
oder die profis teil ihrer rente was mit
ihnen los
carsten nulle teig kneten ich fühle mich
wie diese wenn die dann beide immer so
die schale einschlagen
also falls ihr mal sauer seit auf
jemanden aggression habt
fertig als topping empfiehlt unsere
koreanische mama zucchini wo sie jetzt
müssen wir unsere zucchini meisten dyson
mensch das sieht ja wirklich praktisch
handlich und super einfach raus aber das
ist mein leben wirklich super stellt
sich noch weiter da ist jetzt die
zucchini science zur seite stellen und
nach 15 minuten ausquetschen danke an
den für diese stäbchen das sind extrem
langes stäbchen er hat gesagt die sind
zum kochen hier ist unser mai die
checkbox muss heißt sein und darüber
dass ladino abkühlen denn es ist heiß
das ist eine schöne brücke von schauen
sie die an die koreanische mama sagt
dass man das jetzt mit dem a7 soll
wie komme ich auf die idee die nur die
suppe zu machen es war ein kalter
herbsttag und ich dachte wo er jetzt
eine leckere hühnersuppe
also habe ich gegoogelt wie man die
suppe selber macht und dann habe ich von
meinem bike waren tagen ein video
gefunden wo er schreibt homemade chicken
durchsucht und dann dachte ich hallo das
ist ja wie
und dann dachte ich
[Musik]
ob und wie hoch ein tables tun so hell
ist jetzt aber nicht nur content der
begeistert wie viel salz davon so eine
suppe euro
unsere kimi hat jetzt durch das salz das
ganze wasser verloren und die kann man
jetzt tatsächlich ausquetschen das ist
eine s t in einer heißen pfanne geben
wird ein bisschen öl rhein soll das
reicht auch und da fügen wir unsere ski
nie dazu
[Musik]
gucken wir uns gleich eine koreanische
serie haben wenn wir die juden haben
dies jetzt sortiert und jetzt müssen wir
das fleisch von unserem check up machen
diese zitieren ist jetzt klein
gestückelt und wir haben geschnittenes
gerupftes münchen das hühnchen kommt
nicht zurück in den topf wie bei uns
deutschen
es wird jetzt gesalzen ein bisschen
gepfeffert jetzt kommt noch ein zähler
für knoblauch pulver drauf und ein
teelöffel vorher weg gemacht und jetzt
wieder fett hinzuzufügen
mit let's get ready to rumble
es ist schon so spät mittlerweile halb
elf hallo lieber teig bist du denn schon
ausgeruht und da willst du nicht mein
tag x an fast so klebrig teig halbieren
so jetzt müssen wir unseren nudelteig
mal hier schön aus rollen was sie das
set fallen aus oder ich mag meine nudeln
bisschen dünner knapp eine minute lang
und hart wir sollten das jetzt zusammen
die schon alte nudel meister von premier
aso an einem feldversuch nummer zwei
jetzt mit
so kombiniert aufmachen wenn unsere gut
zur fähigkeit scheitert haben wir immer
noch unsere maschinen wenn ich gerade an
das ausrollen denke das ist ja so viel
einfacher schade wie schön es aussieht
naja schiff angegriffen und am
donnerstag mit speisestärke das ist
jetzt die nudel hier
den rest geben ich sag noch 100 mal im
video ist dran
guck mal ich mach jetzt auch die nudeln
fertig und bewegungs sammeln sie gekocht
sind
kein wunder dass jay hob über 70 singt
es ist einfach die anstrengendste suppe
der welt die nudeln fertig gibt zwei
arten nudeln gemacht man kann nudeln
machen war man kann nur du machen kann
es einmal so dicke dinger die aussehen
wie selbst geschnitten und einmal so
rahmen artige weil mich diese ganze
suppe auch ein bisschen an dramen
erinnert hat als grundlage für unsere
dicken nur dazu brauchen wir nur das
erinnert mich echt nachahmen suppe unser
erstes topping ist natürlich dass
schicken
dann kommen natürlich unsere zucchinis
nach oben drauf so daneben
jetzt braucht
oma so kommen wir probieren jetzt und
hier haben wir unsere chicken nudelsuppe
es so oder anders zeit um ein grad wird
es so oder anders sein
das ist eine koreanische so da dieser
nach suite ist ingenieur estland schluck
trinken post leute es mir kalt nachts
sind es vorweihnachtlich und süß und was
ist das okay dies so dass es nicht so
gut
wir hätten lieber eine sprite kaufen
soll nicht weiß und nun stellen uns
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmeckt schicken nur des aushubs
schicken
[Musik]
die zucchini ist so lecker aber es ist
so ein richtiges herbst essen
aber wer macht sich sowas wer macht so
was für zu hauen wer stellt sich da drei
stunden die küche glaube aber dass sie
mit diesen dünnen rahmen nudeln bisschen
besser schmeckt gramm nudeln einfach
nicht mehr so leute ganz lapidar dass
ihr das video angeschaut habt und ich
hoffe euch hat das video gefallen auch
wenn ich kurz vor einem mental breakdown
stehe bei dieser suppe einfach so viel
zeit gekostet hat aber gut ding will
weile haben das wisst ihr auch was soll
ich jetzt nächstes kochen schafft es mir
mal gerne in die kommentare wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder
und vergesst nicht checken schicken
single ist oder an zeit